le projet d'exportation d'électricité
d'hydro-québec vers le massachusetts
soulève une vive opposition de la part
des écologistes et résidents tu m'aides
c'est un projet qui est important pour
hydro québec mais non seulement pour
hydro-québec pour le québec en entier
je vois d'énormes avantages pour
l'environnement cette énergie propre qui
vient du québec pas se substituer au
pétrole et au gaz naturel
les gens ne viennent pas ici pour voir
des lignes électriques sous les notes il
n'aurait pas pu choisir un pire endroit
les gens disent il déteste ce projet
importe qu'il soit d'extrême droite
des supporters de tram ou d'extrême
gauche ils sont unis contre ce projet
parce qu'ils aiment cette région et
qu'on veut la saccager
dans l'état du maine un projet
d'hydro-québec soulève la controverse
dans un camp comme dans l'autre on
évoque le même argument la protection de
l'environnement
hydro-québec et son partenaire américain
centcom in town promettent de réduire
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
nouvelle angleterre
les opposants disent vouloir sauvegarder
l'une des dernières forêts sauvages de
la côte est des états unis
les gens ne vont pas se laisser faire on
va se battre
[Musique]
en 2018 hydro-québec décroche le plus
important contrat d'exportation de son
histoire
l'état du massachusetts à la recherche
d'énergie propre pour réduire ses
émissions de gaz à effet de serre choisi
l'hydroélectricité du québec
le contrat prévoit l'exportation de 9,45
térawattheures annuellement pendant 20
ans assez pour alimenter environ un
million de maisons
certes c'est le plus gros contrat pour
hydro québec
mais c'est aussi un énorme pas en avant
dans la lutte aux changements
climatiques
massachusetts plus que la moitié de
l'électricité est produite par des
centrales gaz naturel beaucoup plus
polluante que les barrages
hydroélectriques dont un seul projet on
va pouvoir réduire annuellement depuis 2
3 millions de tonnes métriques
d'émissions de gm
c'est comme si on enlevait des routes
700 mille voitures chaque année donc
c'est un énorme pas il si on regarde les
autres projets sur la planche à dessin
il y en a pas un qui permet de faire un
pas aussi important en nouvelle
angleterre en ce moment pour alimenter
le massachusetts hydro québec projette
de construire une ligne courant continu
de 320 kg vol elle a d'abord tenté de la
faire passer par le new hampshire mais
en 2019 elle a dû abandonner le projet
baptisée norton passe à cause d'une
opposition populaire est mise maintenant
sur le projet neo in green clean energy
kinect cette nouvelle ligne de transport
d'électricité relierait le poste des
appalaches
pretec free minds jusqu à lewiston dans
le sud du maine à cet endroit les lignes
se connecteraient au réseau de la
nouvelle angleterre donc ici au poste
des appalaches qui est derrière nous
donc ça sera le point de départ de la
ligne il ya des équipements spécialisés
qui vont être installées dans garde un
convertisseur qui va être installé qui
permet de transformer le courant
alternatif du réseau d'hydro-québec en
courant continu
au québec la ligne doit parcourir 103 km
jusqu'à la municipalité de frontenac
[Musique]
le tracé celui des lignes électriques
existantes sur 72% du parcours
de la frontière jusqu'à lewiston le
partenaire d'hydro-québec centro
manpower pour prendre le relais et
construire une ligne de 233 km ici aussi
les deux tiers du parcours
suivent un couloir de lignes existantes
mais dans le nord sur 85 km il faudrait
ouvrir un nouveau corridor à travers un
paysage montagneux couvert de forêts
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans la petite communauté de west fox la
colère gronde
c'est la plus grande étendue de ferait
non fragmenté dans l'est des états unis
il n'y a pas d'endroit plus sauvage sur
la côte est la première route asphaltée
et à 40 km on est au milieu de nulle
part
le biologiste jean mène des projets de
conservation pour tribes permettait d'
un organisme qui veille à la protection
des écosystèmes aquatiques
[Musique]
parce que la forêt est intacte il y à
tout un réseau de ruisseaux de rivière
de la kids étant interconnectés
[Musique]
c'est le royaume de l'omble de fontaine
il y en a dans les étangs partout autour
l'omble de fontaine est adepte d'eau
claire et fraîche
pour les écologistes c'est une espèce
emblématique
c'est le signe d'un écosystème en santé
l'omble de fontaine est extrêmement
sensible
si l'eau devient trop chaude trop salée
aussi en introduit des espèces
envahissantes
elle va disparaître
jeff une nouvelle ligne de transport
pourrait compromettre l'un des derniers
bastions d'espèces aux états unis
[Musique]
sur les 85 premiers kilomètres la ligne
va croiser des ruisseaux à 200 reprises
en ce moment ce sont des endroits boisés
et ombragé les feuilles tombent dans les
ruisseaux et donne à manger aux insectes
qui à leur tour nourrissent les poissons
les arbres vieillissants tombe dans les
ruisseaux et fournissent des abris en
déboisement pour la ligne on va détruire
ces labitrie
ce ruisseau coolstream inquiète chez
frieden c'est un important site de frais
pour l'omble de fontaine
le biologiste a travaillé pendant des
années pour le protéger depuis sa source
jusqu'à son embouchure une seule lisière
de 150 mètres de largeur en bordure
d'une route forestière a échappé aux
projets de conservation jefferies origin
a récemment appris que cinq roumains pas
un compte et y faire passer sa ligne de
transport on aurait peut-être mis notre
argent ailleurs sachant que ce serait le
site du plus gros projets de
développement dans l'état depuis les 50
dernières années
la biologiste et elle craint que le
corridor énergétique
le fragment qu'ils habitats d'espèces
terrestres comme la martre des pins il
leur faut un très grand domaine vital
compte tenu de leur taille la femelle a
besoin de territoire équivalent à 400
terrains de football pour le mal c'est
deux fois plus ils ont aussi besoin
d'arbres rapprocher les uns des autres
pour sauter et éviter de se retrouver
sur le sol d'autres espèces pourraient
décliner la forêt en bordure du corridor
pourrait être abandonnée par les
amphibiens et certains oiseaux de les
bordures des forêts sont plus exposés au
vent et au soleil
ces conditions se répercute sur les
dizaines ou même des centaines de mètres
à l'intérieur de la forêt dans le maine
on a une vingtaine d'espèces d'oiseaux
chanteurs le nas et dont on sait qu'elle
doit vivre loin des bordures plus on
fragmente la forêt plus on réduit leur
territoire
mais
aux craintes des écologistes les
promoteurs du projet dans le maine comme
fring henson répondent que cette forêt
est déjà fragmenté ce n'est pas une
forêt vierge
elle est exploitée par l'industrie
forestière depuis plusieurs générations
si vous regardez une carte aérienne vous
allez voir que la région est sillonnée
de route forestière le corridor
énergétique n'aura pas plus d'impact
comme jamais
[Musique]
c'est vrai qu'on voit du poids sortir de
la forêt des sons qui ont été coupés
mais ça m'embête pas les gens qu'ils
arrêtent de couper la forêt repousse et
les routes se referme la ligne de
transport
elle sera toujours là on parle d'énormes
structures d'acier de quelques mètres de
largeur et d'une trentaine de mètres de
hauteur
myners a travaillé pendant huit ans
comme guide de rafting dans la région
depuis il a démarré une petite
entreprise qui installent des panneaux
solaires à une centaine de kilomètres
d'ici il a cofondé c'est naturel ici ici
l'un des principaux groupes d'opposition
au projet new green green angie connect
on est presque au sommet de la montagne
enchanté pylônes tout près d'ici
il craint que la ligne de transport
nuise à l'industrie récréotouristique
pourquoi conduirait dans un endroit
reculé si c'est pour voir une énorme
lignes électriques au sommet des
montagnes
nous avons suivi matois ne le long de
l'appellation créer un sentier de
randonnée qui s'étire de la georgie
jusqu'au maine sur 3500 kilomètres
plusieurs randonneurs le parcours de
bout à l'autre
sept sont historiques pour beaucoup de
randonneurs c'est un rite de passage il
devine ici pour se recentrer se
reconnecter à la nature cette partie la
plus sauvage pour beaucoup de
randonneurs c'est l'apogée d'ici jusqu'à
la fin au sommet du mont catane
dans cette partie du sentier une ligne
de transport d'électricité
coop déjà la police entre ses pilotes
font 10 ou 12 mètres de hauteur
la nouvelle ligne serait trois fois plus
haut à la verrez duo de plusieurs
sommets dans les environs parce qu'elle
serait au dessus de la limite des arbres
au mode mai dernier les opposants ont
subi une défaite importante
après un examen de deux ans et demi le
département de la protection de
l'environnement du maine a donné son feu
vert
construction de la ligne de transport il
a conclu que le promoteur avait choisi
le meilleur tracé possible
l' agence publique impose toutefois
plusieurs conditions à sainte-florine
parole plutôt que de déboiser sur une
largeur de 45 m comme c'était
initialement prévu
syndrome ntahwa de faciliter une largeur
de 16 mètres et aménagé de part et
d'autre du corridor une zone de
transition à quelques endroits
particulièrement sensible des arbres
matures pour repousser sous la ligne
on a relevé la hauteur des pylônes là où
l'on veut assurer le passage des serres
et d'autres espèces à ces endroits les
arbres pour en pousser jusqu'à maturité
le départ
centro manpower devra protéger des sites
d'hivernage pour les chevreuils
elle devra aussi créé une vaste zone de
conservation 160 km² qu'en périphérie de
la ligne les opposants jugent les
mesures insuffisantes
c'est du maquillage c'est mieux que rien
mais ça ne protégera pas les écosystèmes
c'est unanime légion du maine déteste ce
projet pourtant une des consignes
ce n'est pas tant la ligne de transport
qui menace la région la plus grande
menace pour la forêt du mais ce sont les
changements climatiques et ce projet va
réduire les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre
nous
[Musique]
la petite ville d'un casta se trouve à
une centaine de kilomètres au sud de
west rock
on est loin de la forêt et des montagnes
mais ici aussi dans la capitale du maine
le projet de ligne de transport
d'électricité fait débat c'est un projet
très prometteur en termes de profits
pour hydro québec
mais rien ne montre qu'il y aura des
bénéfices pour le climat
puis des déchets me dirige naturiste
george karl mais cette organisation
environnementale a commandé un rapport
énergie advisers une petite firme de
consultants de bostens
selon ce rapport hydro québec font déjà
toute l'énergie qu'elle produit sur les
marchés nord américains à partir du
moment où elle enverrait d'énergie vers
le massachusetts
d'autres clients comme l'état de new
york le nouveau brunswick en seraient
privés et devrait se tourner vers des
solutions de rechange comme des
centrales au gaz
si le massachusetts réduit ses émissions
carbone mais que l'état de new york sont
les siennes on n'a rien gagné
hydro-québec veut détourner son énergie
pour maximiser ses profits parce que le
massachusetts est prêt à payer plus cher
pour de l'énergie propre
hydro québec assure qu'elle a l'énergie
nécessaire pour alimenter le
massachusetts en privé ses clients
actuels qui omettent de considérer si le
fait qu'hydro québec au début des années
2000 a lancé une vague d'ajoutent
capacités de production on a construit
des centrales on est en train de
rajouter la dernière de cette vague de
constructions si on veut qu'ils aient
avec le complexe la romaine on se
retrouve avec 5000 mégawatts
approximativement de nouvelles capacités
de production non seulement y at-il plus
de barrages mais niveau d'eau dans les
réservoirs est à la rousse dans le
contexte des changements climatiques
on prévoit une augmentation des
précipitations dans le nord du québec là
où se trouvent les installations de
production d'hydro-québec
[Musique]
pierre olivier pineau et expert en
politiques énergétiques et professeur à
hec montréal
à son avis le raisonnement selon lequel
la nouvelle ligne de transport ne ferait
que déplacer de l'énergie sans bénéfice
pour le climat n'était pas la route
c'est un argument qui est vraiment très
étrange et que je refuse d'accepter
à court terme ça peut être vrai il faut
l'admettre que ça peut être vrai que
hydro québec yvan présente dix térawatts
à new york qui pourrait dire mais là on
a un contrat avec massachusetts on va
prendre ses distances est convenu york
on les vend massachusetts mais l'état de
new york à des engagements de 2 en
termes d'énergies renouvelables et de
réduction de gaz à effet de serre donc
ils ne vont pas pouvoir combler ce
déficit avec du gaz naturel parce que ce
n'est pas renouvelable et donc ça va
inciter des nouveaux projets d'énergie
renouvelable
aux etats unis les opposants soulève une
autre objection
la nouvelle ligne de transport lui ré
aux projets locaux d'énergie verte comme
le solaire ou l'éolien
hydro québec soutient le contraire on
n'est pas en compétition avec eux mêmes
sur le long terme
l'hydroélectricité du québec est
extrêmement bien placé pour fournir un
support à ces énergies l'heure les
énergies solaire et éolienne sont
intermittentes
quand il n'ya pas de soleil quand le
vent ne souffle pas les panneaux
solaires et les éoliennes ne produisent
pas d'électricité
pendant ces périodes de creux il faut se
tourner vers l'énergie stockée dans des
batteries
[Applaudissements]
les serveurs d hydro-québec pourrait
servir de batteries naturel en quelque
sorte le cas du québec est unique sur
terre parce qu'on a des réservoirs d'une
capacité inégalée dans les réservoirs
eau mais des milliards de kilowattheures
en stockage qui peuvent être là pour
plusieurs années selon une étude de
l'université du hem haïti à boston il
faudrait construire quatre nouvelles
lignes de transport 2000 mégawatts entre
le québec et la nouvelle angleterre
si on veut optimiser les coûts de la
transition énergétique
ces quatre fois le projet new england
green energy connecte en grandissant au
québec j'ai toujours une ligne
électrique qui j'en ai j'ai grandi en
partie au chalet de mes parents avec une
ligne électrique dans dans le fond ça
m'a jamais gêné ça faisait partie il
s'est intégré au paysage pour moi
c'est certain que quand une nouvelle
ligne électrique arrive c'est un
changement et tout changement pose des
problèmes d'acceptabilité maintenant il
faut prendre ça dans le contexte la
décarbonisation pour lutter contre les
changements climatiques
il va falloir faire des changements au
québec
quelques voix s'élèvent contre le projet
de nouvelle ligne de transport
d'électricité
surtout tête running la ville s'opposent
au tracé dans le quartier black lake
ici les pilotes doivent suivre une ligne
existante derrière des maisons lorsqu'on
est devant la maison voit pratiquement
pas de pilotes derrière l'on parle de
plomb du roi 3 fois plus au sol c'est
possible d'apporter orlan est donc
vraiment beaucoup d'incompréhension
selon le maire la nouvelle ligne risque
de bloquer tout nouveau projet de
développement résidentiel dans le
quartier parce qu'ailleurs c'est du
sorte de 1000 d'ailleurs c'est des
montagnes russes du pailhasse élites
roumaines comme ça on peut seulement
construire ou est ce que vous pensez la
ligne la ville demande à hydro québec de
modifier son tracé pour emprunter
d'anciens terrains miniers et nous ont
dit peut passer d'abord quand vous
traversez le tout est raide amen on voit
ici un peu de colère
la végétation il y en a pas on coupe un
peu près pas d'armes non plus
[Musique]
un peu plus au sud le tracé intercepte
l'extrémité sud ouest du parc national
de frontenac sur une distance de 590
mètres le long d'une ligne existante la
loi sur les parcs est bien clair on peut
pas pas d'exploration d'exploitation ou
de transport de toutes formes d'énergie
dans les parcs nationaux dont salle
inclut aussi les lignes d'électricité
la parcelle de terrain qu'on doit passer
la ligne avaient été ajoutés pour
aménager une entrée à partir de la route
161 ce poste d'accueil n'a jamais vu le
jour
c'est vraiment une partie qui est
adjacente qui qui qui sort du parc
national de frontenac et que pas une
grande valeur écologique
alors pour nous c'est correct de
soustraire cette superficie la du parc
national de frontenac à condition qu'on
compense pour cette perte de superficie
d'une façon exemple nature québec
demandent qu'on modifie les limites du
parc ont vu deux quadruples la
superficie qui perdu et la mettre en
espace naturel protégé
autour du parc on va s'assurer comme ce
que votre précédent que c'est pas facile
finalement de modifier comme ça les
limites de parts
hydro québec est en pourparlers avec le
ministère de la forêt de la fournée des
parcs ainsi qu'avec la sépaq
elle évalue aussi la possibilité
d'ajuster son tracé à ted friedmann
sommes pas des spécialistes tracé de
ligne dont le bureau d'audiences
publiques sur l'environnement le bape
doit remettre un rapport d'ici le 19
novembre sont les impacts du projet au
québec question est occupé
couche-tard la verra demain
du côté américain hydro-québec et centro
manpower attendent encore deux permis
important au niveau fédéral
les promoteurs du projet ont échappé un
projet de référendum que les opposants
voulaient tenir dans le maine au mans
d'élection présidentielle le 3 novembre
prochain
la cour suprême de l'état a jugé que le
projet de référendum
elle est contre la constitution je suis
très excité on est prêt à commencer la
construction il ya deux ans et demi on
nous a dit que la ligue allait être
construite au plus vite des choses n'ont
pas bougé
ce projet est mort
pierre olivier pineau crois que les
groupes d'intérêts de part et d'autre
devrait mettre leurs différentes cotées
ou non du climat si on y va au cas par
cas qu'à chaque ligne de transmission ya
une nouvelle bataille juridique des
nouvelles menaces de référendum locaux
des nouvelles négociations
on n'en finira pas parce que ce n'est
que le début de la décarbonisation
[Musique]
au début du mois d'octobre cinq nations
autochtones du québec ont envoyé un
mémoire au gouvernement américain pour
s'opposer au projet new england clean
energy connect
elle soulève qu'une grande partie des
installations production d'hydro-québec
se trouvent sur leur territoire et
qu'elles n'ont jamais reçu de
compensation pour l'exploitation de
leurs ressources
les premières nations demande aux états
unis de ne pas y mettre de permis
présidentielle un des deux permis
fédéraux attendu par hydro-québec et 5
selon manpower pour démarrer la
construction de la ligne de transport
hydro québec répond que c'est aux
gouvernements du québec et du canada de
trancher sur les revendications
territoriales des nations autochtones